[Musica]
sono sopravvissuto
sono miracolato
io ero
era
questo
e i tempi non scherzavo ero un
regolatore
in pratica negli anni 75 76 77
non c'erano gratta vinci non c'erano
macchinette quindi a milano c'erano le
bische clandestine
ogni bisca clandestina era sotto
controllo di una cosca
il mio capo homos come si dice mi
mandava controllare queste piazze le sue
piazze io guardavo calcolavo insieme un
altro signore se questa gente scremava
dei soldi al mio capo
se lo faceva allora io andavo a parlare
c'era delle fraseologie nell'ambito
della malavita
tipo che te lo dico a fare
le imprese queste cose non se lo fa
ripetere note lo fa ripetere dopo voleva
dire un colpo di pistola
magari nella gamba
o una randellata in faccia o cose di
questo tipo
si guadagnava tanti soldi
io avevo tanti soldi
tantissime volte non sono arrivato allo
scontro fisico perché avevo una
gestualità e un modo di parlare con
queste persone che gli fece ho paura e
mi sentivo dio
ma io mi facevo
e quello era il mio inferno mi facevano
speedball perché lo speedball poi facevo
un po di cocaina un po di eroina sentivo
la botta dell'eroina ma non ero il
tossico
stravolto per terra dovevo avere un tono
perché giravo colpo nel mio caso perché
devo andare a far paura e mi sentivo dio
fino a che un giorno sono andato a villa
sperlinga palermo a controllare
la bisca di questo signore abbastanza
importante mandato dal mio capo
e da lì ho capito che io non ero via
perché lui a un certo punto se n'è
accorto che io mi facevo nella
tossicodipendenza
600 in ogni campo 60
figuratevi nella malavita nella malavita
poi ha un alto livello
se tu sei tossicodipendente sei un
infame se una persona che dopo due
giorni in galera
parla
magari io non l'avrei fatto però
non puoi permetterti di farti non puoi
permettere di essere tossicodipendente
nella malavita e lui se n'è accorto se
n'è accorto ha chiamato uno delle sue
guardie del corpo ne hanno mandato
nell'altra sala
hanno messo un telo di cellophane per
terra sopra a un tappeto appena preso
dalla moglie e vi ho detto scusami sai
metto questo cellophane perché poi sai
il sangue le cose quindi erano per
levare perché sai sapete nuovo e io ho
detto a figurativo e ormai perché nei
film il tipo tira fuori e pugno cannone
no nella realtà tu sei lì e speri dio fa
che questo sia un killer serio che mi
tira giù dalle spese muoio basta perché
se sbaglia magari mango usciamo tutta la
vita il mio pensiero era quello poi
ho cominciato a pensare ma aspetta un
attimo lui continua a fare lo sborone
perché io dica al mio boss di milano che
cosa fa quindi il mio boss di milano è
più forte di lui e allora gli dico
guarda scusami prima ad ammazzarmi
perché è giusto che tu lo faccia
chiama mario
prova dirglielo dai
guarda questo è così così così io non
ero affiliato quando tu sei affiliato
allora c'è bisogno di una commissione
che decreta la tua morte io non un
soldato a un certo livello non soldato
quindi bastava un sì del mio capo e ero
morto
dall'altra parte del telefono per i non
c'era agevolare la chiamata al bar di
lui ha detto valterino non si tocca lo
uccido io a milano bene ho fatto il
viaggio punta raisi milano dovete
immaginare che amavo la hostess presto
mi dia un minion anzi due anzi tre
guardavo continuamente il mare il cielo
dice una donna che bello che vive vero
dio mio per i bambini ma questo non
fuori richiamavo l'oste c'è qualcosa da
mangiare ma no qualcos'altro ha bisogno
di ri di di mangiare posso fumare ma no
ma non si può fumare tutto così arrivo a
milano mi prendono a mazzate c'è un
picchiato forte ma va detto non ti
voglio uccidere perché mi voleva bene
come un figlio
aveva un figlio ma non andava d'accordo
con lui lui vedeva in me il suo delfino
di fatti mi dava delle delle chicche di
saggezza tipo la droga ricordati che non
si fa la droga si vende o altrimenti
stai sotto tono e non far vedere che
magari tu sarai il boss di un domani
poi cosa è successo è successo che è
crollato il mio mondo ormai non ero più
nessuno non potevo girare come prima
avevo perso il rispetto
e quindi mi è crollato tutto addosso
cominciato andare come gli altri a fare
i movimenti
piccoli scippi e storie di questo tipo
perché la mentalità del
tossicodipendente cambia totalmente
con la mentalità normale cioè il tosto e
violente vede una donna con una catena
d'oro e non pensa anche bella quella
catena don nolli penso che la catena
loro pesa 20 grammi io la prendo la vado
a vendere mi faccio quindi io ho più
diritto di avere st catena e tela
strappo e tela scippo perché tu la metti
su solo per fartela vedere dagli altri
invece mi serve perché io sto male e con
questa mentalità vai a delinquere e poi
magari ti arrestano io sono contro il
carcere per i tossicodipendenti certo da
chiudere ma da chiudere con delle
persone che ti possono star vicino con
delle persone che ti possano capire con
delle persone che ti possono insegnare i
sentimenti i sentimenti si insegnano
si insegnano così come le regole
c'era un famosissimo psichiatra che era
andato a intervistare un ragazzo in
carcere a regina coeli questo va
stuprato una ragazza e gli ho detto
perché hai stuprata perché mi piaceva ma
ti rendi conto che tu hai stupra adesso
cosa fatto perché non avendo 9 a regole
il tossicodipendente queste regole le
azzera le azzera l'uomo la donna
la zona tra si dipendenza
veramente una tragedia più dell'uomo
perché l'uomo bene o male s'arrangiava
fa le rapine scippi ma una donna su
tutto sei bella cosa da vende il suo
corpo
e della prima cosa che vende dopo aver
venduto i giovani di famiglie i soldi e
tutto è di fare un lavoro poi per
tirarla su da questo inferno incredibile
io sto seguendo una ragazza
che si è fatta per dieci anni da 16 anni
e comincia da farsi
fino a 26 anni si è fatta mi ha chiamato
lo prese in carico sebbene io lavoro 118
e sembra un ragazzo e
scrivo ho scritto un libro in braccio
destro e
non avevo il tempo materiale
però ho cominciato a starle dietro ho
cominciato a capire che
dinamiche gli scattavano per farsi e lei
ma sempre detto a me vendere il mio
corpo non era vendere dio con noi a
prostituirsi era un mezzo per farmi
e quindi da lì ho capito che era molto
più difficile
ogni giorno ci chiamavamo ogni giorno io
ricevo di fare certi esercizi
di tirarsi su di ritornare donna
che sono 100 giorni che non si fa
questa ragazza
sta bene adesso sto molto bene io gli
voglio un bene della madonna
perché la porterò nella comunità quando
io finirò col 118 voglio più una
comunità ma non per farle a roma per
carità
l'eroe
la gente che muore l'eroe io voglio fare
questa cosa per dare quella fortuna
ripari con la fortuna che ho avuto
e siccome conosco le dinamiche della
tosca e violenza della malavita
cerco di dare dei nuovi sentimenti
cerco di dare amore ma amore vero
determinazione
per far rifiorire
quel lampo di vita che si è spento il
documento è cominciato a farti perché la
droga che uccide prima dentro e poi
piano piano fuori
voglio solo dire
uno di queste mia figlia è nata san
patrignano
felice docu film stampa
pensate ha avuto 51 milioni
telespettatori
e io che non volevo dire la mia storia
51 milioni adesso e quindi ho detto
vabbè a sto punto mi gioco tutto e
cominciò
a parlare ho cominciato andare anche
nelle scuole
nelle scuole medie grazie a luiz a chi
ne ha fatto andare a parlare coi ragazzi
e sapere che non pensavo mi seguissero
così ed è una cosa pazzesca perché hanno
mille risposte da internet ma tutte
sconnesse tutte strane io le porte
invece nella realtà e li faccio
camminare dall'inizio gli dico come
fatta
gli parlo del th ucciderla che adesso
non hanno hanno rovinato del del fumo e
insieme facciamo dei ragionamenti
atti a
allontanarli da questi sbagli molto
pericolosi
voglio concludere con
questo cantante
che ha fatto scusate
io con vincenzo
io le conferenze ed eccolo
franco simone franco simone ne anni 70
56 fa questa canzone cara droga dove
tutti gli altri cantanti scimmiottavano
sisters mofy eroina brown sugar arriva
lui e cosa fa questo splendido ragazzo
fa una poesia e la mette in musica e
l'adesivo con una donna
questa canzone ascoltatela quando magari
andata a casa o
o su youtube ci mettete un minuto
ascoltatela che bella vi dico solo il
ritornello voglio maledirci raccolgo le
forze per guidarti
la rabbia che posso che sola posso darti
con l'anima a pezzi ormai voglio che ti
resti il mio disprezzo come sola mia
eredità
come se la mia
[Musica]
[Applauso]